[Applause]
looking ahead to five more years in
power serbian president alexander vucic
hailed his win as a historic victory
[Applause]
i will be the serb who's been in power
in our country for the longest time
i'm not someone who's proud and proud of
power but i am humble in front of my
people who made it possible for me with
their trust
vucic won decisively taking around three
times the votes of his nearest rival his
ruling party also swept to victory in
parliamentary elections
some in the opposition accused him of
rigging the vote vuchich accuses them of
trying to do the same thing
despite admitting defeat this time his
main rival says a growing number of
voters are ready for change
these elections are the beginning of the
end of
we will not be waiting four years for
the next elections at least
parliamentary elections we will not and
cannot betray serbian citizens who stood
up today masses of people masses of
young people spilled to the streets and
polling stations
but looming over the entire affair was
the shadow of the war in ukraine
the russian invasion happened just days
into the election campaign
while his rivals pledged to combat
corruption it was vutice's promises of
stability and neutrality that may have
tipped things in his favor
we believe that we face many challenges
but that the most important thing for
serbia is to have good relations in the
region to continue its european path on
the other hand but at the same time not
to ruin its ties with traditional
friends
serbia has long been a traditional ally
of russia
but it also wants good relations with
the west as aspires to membership of the
european union
that's made its foreign policy a
difficult balancing act
serbia joined a u.n resolution
condemning the russian invasion but so
far it's refused to impose any sanctions
this window is closing i don't think in
europe you can really have a very good
relations with russia in the same time
pushing uh further for eu integration so
he would be really tempted to change
that policy and there would be a huge
pressure from eu our economy is actually
basically completely dependent on uh on
eu
bootage's hold on power seems secure for
now but his international position is
more precarious russia and the west are
more divided than at any time in recent
history and for serbia it may grow
increasingly difficult to resist taking
a side vincent molin al jazeera